[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue ça vous regarde en
direct je suis ravi de vous retrouver au
sommaire ce soir le plan de sobriété du
gouvernement après des semaines de
réflexion Elizabeth borde a présenté les
mesures d'économie d'énergie qui seront
demandées à chacun d'entre nous et elle
touche tous les secteurs de la société
pour passer l'hiver ces mesures sont
incitatives pas de contraintes
sont-elles justes et surtout efficaces
est-ce que les Français seront au grand
rendez-vous de civisme qu'on leur
propose grand débat ce soir avec nos
invités dans un instant notre grand
témoin vient nous parler et d'une série
documentaire exceptionnelle c'était la
guerre d'Algérie 5 épisodes d'archives
inédites pour retracer la genèse du
drame qui opposa la France à l'Algérie
de 1954 à 1962 diffusés toute cette
semaine sur LCP sur les plateformes de
notre chaîne il est signé Benjamin Stora
ce documentaire historien dans toute
l'oeuvre est consacrée à cette mémoire
et ce passé qui ne passe pas il sera
avec nous ce soir enfin trois affranchis
trois parties pris ce soir Clément
Perrot a suivi le colloque des cadres du
RN à l'Assemblée pour célébrer
discrètement les 50 ans du parti le
pénis un nouveau village ce soir ffteel
de libération pour nous parler ville et
territoire et puis une nouvelle histoire
d'école de l'enseignant Yanis roder
voilà pour le menu ce soir c'est parti
[Musique]
pas moins de 9 ministres mobilisés et
autour d'eux une chef d'orchestre
Elisabeth borne chargée de la
planification écologique le plan de
sobriété du gouvernement a donc été
présenté en grande pompe vous le voyez
cet après-midi c'était Porte de
Versailles la lutte anti-gaspi au
service d'un objectif et il est de
taille moins 10% d'énergie consommée
d'ici deux ans 2024 le tout sans
contrainte est-ce que c'est possible
bonsoir Antoine Armand bonsoir et merci
d'être avec nous vous êtes député
Renaissance le parti présidentiel député
de Haute-Savoie bonsoir Anne Drago et
merci d'être là vous êtes la
coordinatrice des programmes au Réseau
Action Climat vous avez d'ailleurs pris
la parole cet après-midi Porte de
Versailles vous nous direz ce que vous
pensez de ce plan juste efficace ou pas
bonsoir Franco Banovic et bienvenue sur
ce plateau président du clef alors c'est
une association d'entreprises
industrielle et tertiaire grande consomm
d'énergie électricité gaz principalement
on peut citer la SNCF Veolia
l'agroalimentaire la grande distribution
au champ Carrefour l'acide urgies donc
c'est très très large et la sobriété
vous connaissez déjà parce que vous
payez plein pot si je veux dire
l'envoler des prix de l'énergie vous
nous expliquerez on a besoin d'un
communiquant ce soir aussi parce que il
faut bien communiquer pour embarquer
tout un pays vers la sobriété ce soir
c'est Franck Tapiro expert en
communication politique qui va nous
rejoindre dans un tout petit instant
mais qu'y a-t-il dans ce plan de
sobriété c'est Stéphane bakowski si j'ai
bien compris qu'il nous le dit tout de
suite
[Musique]
bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir à toutes
bonsoir à tous si j'ai bien compris ce
soir si j'ai bien compris Myriam donc
vous le disiez cet après-midi le
gouvernement a présenté un grand plan
d'urgence pour éviter que cet hiver la
France soit plongée dans le froid et
dans la nuit alors moi je dramatise un
peu mais bon pour faire monter
l'audience c'est le principe de l'info
sauf que le gouvernement évidemment
cherche exactement l'effet inverse
surtout ne pas s'inquiéter parce que si
on fait tous un petit effort de sobriété
la main dans la main et en gardant le
sourire si possible et ben tout devrait
bien se passer regardez le clip de
campagne
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour économiser l'énergie on agit on
réduit chaque geste compte je baisse
j'éteins je décale
et ben voilà c'est très simple ça n'a
rien d'inquiétant de la communication ça
te fait la psychologie alimentaire quand
on annonce une très mauvaise nouvelle à
quelqu'un il faut toujours faire preuve
d'un minimum de tactes et là on se rend
compte qu'en fait le l'objectif fixé par
le gouvernement demande quand même un
gros effort je montre les chiffres qui
sont mis en avant ils seront pas très
spectaculaire en soi mais ce que ça veut
dire c'est qu'on avait prévu jusque là
de réduire de 40% notre consommation
d'énergie d'ici 2050 donc vous pouvez
lisser un effort de 2% de consommation
en moins chaque année la d'un seul coup
on voit bien que ça s'accélère nettement
en deux ans on va faire un effort de
10%, donc si cette accélération se
renforcement de la sobriété se maintient
ce rythme là ça veut dire que on doit se
serait à -40% de consommation dès 2030
20 ans plus tôt donc on parle quand même
pas un gros effort c'est vrai que
présenter comme ça c'est un peu plus
raide
d'où l'important c'est évidemment de la
communication c'est pour ça que Franck
Tapiro a bientôt s'installer à ma place
donc ce que fait le gouvernement c'est
plutôt que de brandir des sanctions
Agnès panure une achète donc il mène la
réforme elle préfère présenter ça un peu
comme un retour aux sources si vous
voulez une sorte d'hommage rendu à la
sagesse de nos grands-parents c'est même
presque attendre il sent qu'on écoute
mais c'est aussi notre changement de
comportement
notre changement
compare à ce que nos grands-parents
faisaient très bien c'est des mesures de
bon sens la chasse au gaspi le sens de
la valeur et du caractère précieux de
cette énergie alors donc on prend la
ministre au pied de la lettre et c'est
vrai qu'il y a 50 ans donc ça date d'un
bout de temps la France avait déjà été
confronté à une grosse crise de
l'énergie le choc pétrolier et bien le
gouvernement à l'époque donnait des
conseils voilà les conseils qu'on
donnait il y a 50 ans on écoute et vous
allez maintenant découvrir le dernier
prototype le modèle anti-gaspi
efficacité immédiate poids 200 g
consommation nu
formidable
chassons les gaspilles de chez nous
il a rien inventé avec son col roulé
Bruno Lemaire
Bruno Le Maire sauf qu'aujourd'hui ce
qui a changé c'est que c'est beaucoup
plus difficile de communiquer comme avec
un peu d'humour comme ça parce que tout
tourne très rapidement chez un faux
réseaux sociaux à la polémique juste
pour le plaisir parce qu'on va faire des
artistes quand même parfois je propose
de regarder le bandeau de BFM pour
illustrer Macron avec un col roulé le
col roulé Macron ça va trop loin
franchement là il y a quand même un
débat sur la sobriété vraiment on en
vient à ce plan parce que l'objectif de
votre papier ce soir qu'est-ce qu'il y a
comme mesure oui parce que c'est sérieux
évidemment et ça personne ne dit le
contraire s'il y a des coupures de gaz
d'électricité cet hiver en France c'est
très sérieux pour ceux qui seront
touchés c'est il a très sérieux pour le
gouvernement parce que ça devrait
changer un petit peu l'ambiance dans le
pays donc la priorité c'est quand même
de convaincre l'ensemble des Français
que ces efforts qu'on demande on ne doit
pas simplement appuyer sur la tête de
des plus faibles pas donner l'impression
qu'il y avait eu bordé auprès des gilets
jaunes éclatent tout le monde à faire un
effort même les plus important même les
plus gros même les plus importants c'est
ce qui explique en gros les ministres ce
qui est important aujourd'hui c'est
cette mobilisation générale que nous
lançons et où les acteurs les plus gros
les plus grandes entreprises les plus
grandes collectivités locales les
administrations montrent l'exemple il
serait inacceptable de demander aux
Français de faire des efforts et que ces
grandes institutions ne fassent pas des
efforts et c'est ça qui compte pour moi
évidemment dans la liste de ceux qui
pourraient montrer l'exemple on aurait
pu ajouter nos milliardaires avec leur
jet privé mais peut-être qu'il y a plus
de place sur la vie je sais pas je crois
que c'est
vous rappeler cette absence de dans la
liste au gouvernement alors les mesures
concrètes les mesures concrètes en fait
on les connaît déjà presque depuis 50
ans la principale levier pour faire
baisser la consommation d'énergie c'est
de baisser le chauffage donc le chiffre
qu'on nous donne c'est 9 % en moyenne 19
pardon oui je suis en pourcent en degrés
donc 19 degrés en moyenne sur la journée
dans les pièces où on vit un peu moins
dans les champs bien sûr beaucoup
d'autres mesures vous avez peut-être
déjà commencé à aller lire si ça
s'affiche chez vous donc voyez
l'administration et les mesures un peu
frappantes comme pas d'eau chaude dans
les sanitaires
on incite au télétravail en augmentant
les primes on demande aux fonctionnaires
qui roulent en voiture de baisser un peu
la vitesse donc pour les entreprises on
peut pas tout détailler il y a des
chartes avec 16 mesures il y aura des
négociations dans chaque entreprise avec
un référent pour faire respecter la
charte et même au niveau du sport vous
voyez les sportifs vont devoir faire un
effort les stades de foot sont éclairés
avec des milliers de projecteurs et bien
il faudra réduire l'éclairage des salles
de 50% avant match alors ça fait quoi
50% de lumière en moins bah je vous
propose de le constater de directement
sur le plateau c'est vrai que vous voyez
que d'un seul coup 50% du miroirs on
voit moins bien donc moi je veux bien
faire ma chronique
avec un peu moins de lumière non en tout
cas c'est pour la bonne cause donc de
tous faire un effort merci infiniment
j'ai tout compris merci Stéphane
j'aimerais
philosophie de ce plan nous parle de
sobriété choisi
la sobriété est une nécessité mais sans
contrainte est-ce qu'elle peut être
vraiment efficace
oui absolument elle peut l'être elle
peut l'être et je voudrais après vous
souligner la philosophie ce plan de
sobriété la philosophie dans la méthode
dans l'esprit et dans les résultats la
méthode c'est d'abord une concertation
la ministre Agnès a mené une
concertation depuis le mois de juin avec
plus de 9 groupes de travail qui
représentent les entreprises les
consommateurs les collectivités les
différents secteurs ensuite l'esprit
c'est ce que vous avez très plaisir
et le civisme le civisme c'est qu'en
fait quand aujourd'hui je fais un effort
sur ma consommation énergétique un
effort que je peux consentir on va
sûrement y revenir et bien je fais un
effort pour le pays pour l'indépendance
énergétique pour nos entreprises qui ne
peuvent pas baisser leurs production et
puis les résultats vous me dites est-ce
que on peut sans contrainte réussir à
des économies des économies d'énergie
oui c'est possible un seul exemple se
chauffer à 19 degrés par exemple si vous
baissez d'un degré votre consommation et
bien vous pouvez gagner 7 % sur votre
facture 7% volume 7% au prix donc des
efforts petit et raisonnables évidemment
je ne parle pas et on y reviendra de
personnes qui tout le monde ne peut pas
faire les mêmes efforts ou en parler les
gens qui sont dans la grande partie
énergétique les personnes qui sont la
grande précarité énergétique et que le
gouvernement soutient par ailleurs par
ailleurs on y viendra ces personnes là
je suis à peu près sûr qu'elle ne se
chauffe pas à 23 degrés en se disant
qu'est-ce qu'on est bien chez soi en
T-shirt donc on parle pas de ces
personnes en grande précarité
énergétique et il faut elle les soutenir
l'idée que l'État doit montrer l'exemple
la partie la plus contraignante c'est
l'état les administrations donc les
fonctionnaires en col roulé pour le dire
vite pas forcément les salariés des
banques à la défense ça c'est c'est
assumé il faut d'abord balayer devant sa
porte donc je suis fier aussi que l'État
prenne ses engagements et disent à la
fois pour ces agents pour ses
équipements nous on va montrer l'exemple
vous montrer que c'est possible sans
affecter la qualité de nos services la
qualité de nos prestations
et sur le caractère de 6 parce que c'est
très important qu'un plan soit juste
pour qu'il soit bien accepté et appliqué
tout à fait on n'a pas beaucoup entendu
effectivement dans la présentation de ce
plan le fait qu'actuellement il y a 12
millions de personnes qui sont précarité
énergétique dont une partie qui se prive
de chauffage donc pour eux quand on dit
ne pas chauffer au-delà de 19 degrés ils
aimeraient bien se chauffer à 19 degrés
ce n'est pas le cas donc il faut non
seulement évidemment expliquer que
c'était pas eux que l'on vise mais ces
ménage là il faut les aider à pouvoir se
chauffer à 19 degrés il faut les aider à
pouvoir se déplacer les aider à pouvoir
se nourrir avec une alimentation saine
et pour l'instant ce qui est proposé
c'est un chèque énergie à 100 ou 200
euros qui courira à peine la hausse du
prix du gaz ou de l'électricité donc on
est très très loin pour déménage qui ne
se chauffait déjà pas de pouvoir les
sortir de leur situation et donc voilà
il y a cet enjeu de justice qui n'est
pas encore pris en charge alors on
termine le tour de table je vous écoute
allez-y juste les entreprises
effectivement c'était très important de
commencer par l'État les entreprises les
collectivités avant de dire aux
particuliers allez-y donc là dessus
c'est quelque chose qu'on avait
effectivement fortement
les grands acteurs économiques
ensuite on aimerait bien qu'il y ait un
suivi parce que les beaux engagements
comme à la défense ou on va baisser de
15 % à la consommation d'énergie dans
les tours moi je signe tout de suite de
l'état des entreprises prennent des
engagements que si elle poste sur la
plateforme on leur demande de mettre
leurs engagements elle s'engage à mettre
aussi le résultat dans 6 mois dans un an
et ce qui a donc des doutes sur sur
l'efficacité exactement on sait que
c'est l'hiver qui est vraiment critique
on se pose des questions de savoir si on
aura des coupures de gaz ou
d'électricité alors Franck roubanovic
joue c'est très différent la situation
pour vous parce que vous vous subissez
de points plein fouet les entreprises
que vous représentez l'envoler des prix
d'énergie expliquait à ce qui nous
regardent concrètement ce que ça veut
dire vous vous n'êtes pas soumis au
bouclier tarifaire la facture a augmenté
de plus 100%
en effet on n'est pas on n'a pas de
bouclier tarifaire dans les entreprises
à part les TPE les toutes petites
entreprises ce qui veut dire qu'entre
2021-2022 on a eu un quasi doublement de
prix entre 2022 2023 on va voir un quasi
triplement de prix donc x 5 en l'espace
de 2 ans c'est pour ça que moi je n'ai
aucune inquiétude sur le fait qu'on va
réussir en tout cas à court terme dans
les six mois dans l'année le plan de
sobriété parce que quand vous avez des
factures qui sont juste intenables pour
des entreprises je peux vous dire
qu'elles vont se mettre en quatre pour
réussir à faire des économies
concrètement donc on est déjà traduit
comment la sobriété par exemple dans
l'acide chirurgie dans la grande
distribution dans les hypermarchés
qu'est-ce qu'on fait très concrètement
alors il faut vraiment différencier les
usages tertiaires des usages industriels
dans les usages tertiaires donc
typiquement dans le commerce dans les
bureaux dans les transports etc
finalement c'est pas très différent de
ce qui est demandé à la maison
on va baisser le chauffage de 2 degrés
on va alors on va éteindre les lumières
un peu plus tôt effectivement et puis
quand on peut on va décaler ça c'est
plus simple c'est plus compliqué mais un
distributeur d'eau peut décaler ses
pompes d'une heure etc en revanche dans
l'industrie c'est très compliqué parce
que quand vous avez un process qui
tourne si vous réduisez vous imaginez
bien que pour les trois intensives ça
fait tellement d'années que
l'électricité coûte cher par rapport à
une production que tous les efforts ont
déjà été faits si vous baissez vous
baissez aussi la production et le
message du gouvernement est clair c'est
pas ça l'objectif l'objectif baisser des
entreprises qui ont dû carrément mettre
la clé sous la porte du Alex il y a des
effets sur l'activité ça c'est il faut
pas dire aux gens c'est forcément la
sobriété joyeuse et heureuse alors
absolument alors c'est pas leur
production elles ont arrêté leur
production et elles vont massivement
commencer à arrêter leur production à
partir de début 2023 parce que quand
vous avez des prix qui triplent ou qui
quintuplent et que derrière vous êtes
sur une concurrence international que
vous pouvez pas impacter vous n'avez pas
le choix donc effectivement on espère je
me tourne vers vers mon collègue
j'espère que le gouvernement entendra ça
il prendra les mesures pour 2023
on a besoin de votre éclairage parce que
on a l'impression de revivre un peu la
même situation que pendant le covid un
gouvernement qui communique et qui
essaye d'inciter sans obliger sans
contraindre déjà le mot de sobriété
est-ce que vous trouvez qu'il est bien
choisi est-ce qu'on aurait pas dû parler
de civisme c'est compliqué quand on
cherche d'abord un thème et puis ensuite
un slogan faut pas avoir peur de faire
des slogans parce que toutes les grandes
politiques ont commencé par des slogans
donc moi ça me fait marrer quand
certains politiques disent oui c'est des
slogans c'est l'incantation depuis le
général de Gaulle jusqu'à aujourd'hui
toutes les grandes politiques ont
commencé avec des slogans forts et
d'ailleurs dans les années 70 il y avait
un grand slow qui disait en France on
n'a pas de pétrole mais on a des idées
donc moi j'aimerais là cette année c'est
en France on a plus de chauffage mais on
est motivé quelque part il faut rester
très positif
de croire n'importe quoi la pub et là et
la communication pour positiver pour
créer le l'engagement pour motiver les
gens pour les mobiliser se mobilise rien
parce regardez comme ça en disant autre
mesure n'a pas marché mais non vous la
juger cette campagne parce qu'on sent
que voilà il y a beaucoup de
communiquant derrière il y a des clips
il y a cette météo de de l'énergie et
coat il y a des mots qui sont utilisés
est-ce que vous avez l'impression
d'ailleurs les sondages le montrent pour
l'instant on n'a pas encore l'hiver dur
mais pour l'instant les Français ils
adhèrent et à des taux bien sûr sondages
très très élevés plus de 80% sont
d'accord pour baisser le chauffage parce
qu'en fait la référence avec le covid
pour moi elle est là on a oublié que ce
qui s'est passé pendant covid on a tous
censé tous plein on va dire oui
privation de liberté etc mais on a vu
qu'après le covid on a gardé des
habitudes du covid le télétravail par
exemple c'est quand même un truc de
dingue c'est une mesure soi-disant
d'urgence pendant le covid et à la fin
du covid on n'a jamais vu autant
télétravail partout dans le monde entier
donc moi je pense exactement la même
chose cette campagne n'est donc celle-ci
la campagne n'est qu'un moyen
si elle est valable dans le temps je
suis convaincu et on parlera après des
défavoriser les 8 millions et demi de
personnes en France qui ont des
problèmes de logement et qui aimeraient
juste être non pas à 19 mais
on peut le voir si dans l'autre sens
imaginons admettons que non pas que ça
n'existe pas mais on parlera de la
partie de gens qui ont eux la chance de
se chauffer vous verrez que beaucoup de
gens garderont ces bonnes habitudes sur
le long terme c'est le pari que je fais
pourquoi parce que je crois en
l’engagement citoyen c'est que c'est un
de mes combats depuis de nombreuses
années je suis convaincu qu'en tant que
citoyen on a vu déjà les bienfaits du
télétravail on l'a sorti du cadre du
covid pour en faire une mesure
maintenant aujourd'hui qui est banal
même banalisé dans le monde entier vous
verrez que passer 19 à 17 il y a les
Français qui vont se dire peut-être on
est habitués à vivre avec moins de
confort et ça le monde entier l'a
compris où il va falloir s'habituer à
moins de confort donc vous êtes un
optimiste mais on n'a pas le choix sinon
ça rattrape et au niveau de l'engagement
et au niveau de la mobilisation et au
niveau politique et on dirait c'est la
fois des politiques parce qu'ils auront
mal vendu grâce à la communication donc
une communication doit être le reflet de
cette envie que les choses changent
réellement sur le long terme pas sur le
coup de terme de ce sera un coup de pub
alors Antoine larmant je vais vous faire
réagir parce que j'ai pas de députés
d'opposition face à vous parce qu'ils
étaient en train de présenter leur
contre-projet de sobriété la nupesse qui
considère que non seulement ce plan sera
pas efficace mais qu'il est injuste
Aurélie trouver député insoumise
nous nous proposons plutôt donc je l'ai
dit de passer l'hiver avec une sobriété
jet privé c'est à dire avec interdiction
forte régulation des plus grosses
consommations des super riches c'est à
dire les consommations qui sont pour le
moins superflu les jets privés les yacht
les voitures de luxe les grands projets
inutiles type d'homme de ce qui
artificiel ou d'homme tropicaux sinon et
bien les seuls qui se verront imposer la
sobriété cet hiver ce seront les ménages
modestes les gymnases les écoles les
piscines en plus des coupures dites
ciblées de gaz ou d'électricité et ce
seront les besoins essentiels qui seront
touchés plutôt que les besoins superflus
voilà ça n'a pas raté à peine présenté
on vous reproche déjà une forme
d'injustice sociale qu'est-ce qui est
prévu dans ce plan pour ceux qui
subissent déjà qui sont victimes de la
précarité énergétique parce que ça c'est
vrai que vous auriez pu avoir une mesure
symbolique qui montre que les plus
riches sont à la même enseigne mais vous
savez contrairement à une partie de la
nups je ne mets pas tous les députés de
la nupestre dans le même panier mais
contrairement à une partie de la nups
qui se comport comme des manipulateurs
de symboles nous nous sommes pas dans la
manipulation de symboles nous essayons
d'avoir des résultats rapides et
concrets et donc notre sujet n'est pas
de savoir si en faisant ça on va avoir
l'air de gens raisonnable de gens
efficaces notre sujet c'est d'arriver à
passer
un symbole hein
prendre un autre exemple pour que ça
soit peut-être moins polémique mais les
écrans publicitaires la publicité nous
incite effectivement la communication
à consommer toujours plus donc on a des
injonctions contradictoires entre un
gouvernement qui nous dit consommer
moins en tout cas d'énergie pour
l'instant et une publicité qui nous
vante des voitures toujours plus grosses
on sait que les SUV c'est grosse voiture
c'est la deuxième cause des hausses
d'émission
et les écologistes c'est qu'au fond vous
n'inscrivez pas votre plan dans la durée
et vous ne vous attaquez pas à autre
chose que l'énergie c'est à dire les
voitures les plus polluantes les avions
pourquoi vous faites pas un grand plan
sur les vêtements ou la viande qu'on
mange par exemple honnêtement vous avez
abordé 12 sujets différents
votre question mais il y a vraiment
énormément de sujets en un seul là on
parle de ne pas faire plus large pour
inscrire la sobriété dans l'adulte on
parle d'un plan de sobriété énergétique
dont le premier but est de passer
l'hiver et dont le deuxième but et dans
le deuxième non non attendez et dans le
deuxième but est dans le attendez je
vais finir s'il vous plaît dans le
deuxième but est d'ancrer dans la durée
pour atteindre les objectifs que votre
collègue tout à l'heure a cité les
objectifs de baisse de la consommation
d'efficacité énergétique de baisse de
démission à effet de serre donc est-ce
qu'on fait des choses en matière
écologique oui je vais pas les prendre
là la prime à la conversion le malus
qu'on va continuer à faire évoluer la
régulation d'un certain nombre de
détails sur les activités polluantes etc
je reviens à la base il y a les
manipulures de symboles et puis il y a
des gens qui agissent on peut dire très
bien demain aux entreprises arrêtez de
produire très bien qu'est-ce qui va se
passer on aura du chômage on aura des
gens encore plus dans la précarité
énergétique se précisément que vous
dénoncez donc nous qu'est-ce qu'on fait
on aide les entreprises je suis d'accord
avec ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure
monsieur
quelle est la question pour les
industriels
la double peine absolument
et la société tout à fait raison et je
reviens sur ce que disait monsieur tout
à l'heure à la fois sur les différences
entre l'usage industriel et sur le
chastercière et sur les philosophie la
philosophie du gouvernement c'est qu'on
n'a pas fait le quoi qu'il en coûte pour
un an après perdre notre tissu
économique et industriel qu'on avait
commencé à revigorer on a commencé à
apporter des aides on a apporté des
aides à un million et demi d'entreprises
pour les plus petites et les plus
vulnérables d'entre elles on a commencé
à apporter des aides pour un certain
nombre d'entreprises hyper énergivores
est-ce que c'est suffisant au vu de la
situation 3% de la facture énergétique
en ca avec des règles sur l'excétamol
brut d'exploitation est-ce que c'est
suffisant au vu de la situation
énergétique clairement non c'est pour ça
qu'on portera dans le projet de loi de
finances des mesures beaucoup plus
fortes pour qu'en 2023 nos entreprises
subsistent j'imagine que vous parlez
directement avec le cabinet de
d'Elisabeth borne pour présenter en
termes d'emplois de chiffre d'affaires
un nom conséquent d'entreprise qu'est-ce
que vous dites avec le cabinet en
réalité
les aides telles qu'elles ont été
calibrées à ce jour
ne peuvent pas répondre aux problèmes
parce que c'est un problème si vous les
aides on est sensé le recevoir à
postériori une fois que l'entreprise est
en déficit une fois qu'elle a dû prendre
la décision d'arrêter sa production
parce qu'une entreprise ne va pas
attendre de savoir quelle aide elle peut
éventuellement toucher pour arrêter sa
production pour faire passer de
l'inflation à ses clients etc nous on
pense que la bonne solution le
gouvernement nous a entendu mais
simplement c'est pas encore mise en
œuvre et puis on espère que ce sera
bientôt le cas vous aurez des mesures de
soutien par rapport aux mesures des
mesures de de modification du design de
marché européen parce que je partais
dans le détail c'est pas le but mais si
vous voulez autant sur le gaz on a un
vrai problème
autant sur l'électricité c'est un choix
de l'Europe que d'avoir un prix qui
indiquait sur le prix du gaz donc on
pourrait tout à fait appliquer une
sobriété ça c'est indiscutable c'est
indispensable pour cet hiver toutes les
n'ayant appris d'électricité qui sera
certes plus élevé qui nous évitera de
fermer nos entreprises
de l'énergie et aujourd'hui à Prague le
président de la République Emmanuel
Macron propose de plafonner les prix du
gaz qui se font de les qui servent à
faire de l'électricité mais comme vous
le disiez Franck Tapiro la société
avance illustration d'un marché de la
sobriété qui est en pleine expansion
avec cette entreprise qui prévoit
d'installer chez les particuliers un
petit boîtier sur chaque radiateur pour
permettre des économies d'énergie
reportage m'a été vraiment avec Elsa
montanava
et vous êtes vous prêt à faire des
efforts pour réduire votre consommation
d'énergie
j'ai le chauffage collectif donc je
serai comme tout le monde on sera à 19
on mettra un puit de plus vous
d'habitude vous chauffer à combien non
[Musique]
c'est ouais ouais bon 19 oui bon on peut
vivre avec 19 alors moi je suis pas
mathématicien des grands théoriciens
mais il paraît que si on baisse d'un
degré ça se ressent pas forcément et ça
peut faire des grosses économies
certains dispositifs permettent déjà de
contrôler sa consommation d'énergie
c'est le cas de ce boîtier installé sur
les radiateurs électriques de niveau
d'utilisation
connecté à une application il fait
office de thermostat à distance
là on a mis à 19 degrés par exemple la
température demandée dans le salon
deuxième principe il permet à Voltalis
de couper votre électricité en cas de
surchauffe du réseau on va s'autoriser à
interrompre sa consommation sur des
durées courtes typiquement 10 minutes en
utilisant l'inertie thermique du
bâtiment et si j'arrête pendant 10
minutes le radiateur chez vous vous
n'allez absolument rien sentir mais 10
minutes de moins de temps en temps tout
au long de l'hiver pour vous ça va faire
une économie sur la facture et si on
choisit bien les moments où on va faire
ces économies de 10 minutes sur chacun
des radiateurs à l'échelle du million de
radiateurs qu'on a déjà raccordés ça
fait un gain très très significatif à
l'échelle de du système électrique
national on appelle cela de l'effacement
diffus à la clé une promesse d'économie
de 15% sur la facture d'électricité des
gestes simples qui semblent parfois
relever du bon sens mais beaucoup de
Français ne sont pas convaincus que les
particuliers soit la clé d'univers sans
pénurie
en la lumière qui allons avoir un énorme
impact sur sur la consommation d'énergie
à l'énation nationale enfin je suis
moins sûr individuellement on peut faire
des choses mais demander aux gens qui
ont pas forcément les moyens parce qu'il
réglera le problème on demande aux
petits gens de faire des efforts alors
que c'est les grandes industries qui
sont censés faire le nécessaire mais
voilà elles vous sont directement
soumises ces questions Antoine Armand
cette idée au fond et on le retrouve
avec la question du climat à quoi bon
faire un petit geste le fameux petit
geste du Colibri si la Chine est l'Inde
sont très polluants c'est c'est un peu
la même chose comment vous allez réussir
à embarquer tout le monde oui alors même
s'il y a quand même une nuance par
rapport à la question du Colibri c'est
que là en l'occurrence les statistiques
physiques montrent que si chacun fait un
petit effort vous avez un impact
national parce que il y a 67 millions de
Français donc on n'est pas tout à fait
dans la même chose contrairement
d'ailleurs quoi qu'on pense sur la
régulation des jets privés ou des yachts
au fait que même si vous reculez tout
vous n'arrivez pas à ce genre d'effet
mais je voudrais revenir sur le sujet
que vous abordiez tout à l'heure madame
parce qu'il est vraiment central de la
précarité énergétique et on voit bien
que c'est ce que les gens nous disent
que les gens me disent aussi sur le
terrain sur l'idée de dire on va quand
même pas demander aux petits à ceux qui
souffrent qui ne peuvent pas se chauffer
à 19 degrés de faire des efforts c'est
absurde il y a deux éléments là-dedans
le premier c'est de soutenir soutenir
soutenir les personnes qui sont dans la
précarité énergétique et qui ne vont pas
changer du jour au lendemain du jour au
lendemain de chaudière c'est pour ça
qu'on a fait les Dofus c'est pour ça
qu'on fait un chèque énergie pour 12
millions de ménages 45 milliards de
boucliers tarifaires pour tout le monde
qui va bénéficier au plus aisé qui ont
des appartements ou des logements plus
grands et donc se chauffe plus un
milliard 8 seulement de chaque énergie
pour les quatre premiers des cils est-ce
qu'il y a pas là
un déséquilibre je crois que
malheureusement c'est très français
quand on a une situation difficile de
vouloir toujours opposer opposé les
entreprises les gros et les petits les
Français qui souffrent et les Français
qui souffrent pas on n'est pas
infini on parle de quel milliards 45
milliards il aurait pu être ciblé
davantage vers les ménages pendant le
plus besoin c'est pas opposé c'est
orienté sur les finances publiques on
verse ceux qui ont le fait madame
simplement
il y a quelque chose que vous disiez
tout à l'heure qui est capital c'est
qu'on ne fait pas que soutenir soutenir
soutenir on le fait ces décisives mais
on veut sortir ces gens de la précarité
on fait maintenant depuis deux ans 700
000 rénovations énergétiques par an ma
prime rénov ça bénéficie aux trois
quarts à des ménages à 20% des ménages
les plus modestes
cet argent ne font pas changer
l'étiquette énergie du logement
c'est-à-dire que c'est un changement de
mode de chauffe pas les ménages les plus
pauvres
le mouvement est bah dans le bon sens
sur la neuve rénovation thermique mais
ça n'est pas suffisant c'est l'ensemble
du logement qu'il faut rendre de la même
manière beaucoup d'argent public mais
qui n'est pas fléchés vers ceux qui en
ont réellement besoin les ménages
modestes et vers des rénovations
performantes pour vraiment apprendre
une nouvelle ère en fait c'est ça et il
faut pas que ce plan s'arrête
à l'hiver ça vous êtes tous d'accord
avec ça parce que c'est aussi ce qui se
passait avec le covid dès qu'on sortait
de la vague le covid repartait moi
j'avais envie de savoir quand même c'est
est-ce que ce sera efficace parce que
quand même on nous dit que réduire 10%
en deux ans est-ce que c'est vraiment
possible si tout est fait dans le plan
du gouvernement la consommation
d'énergie diminuerait de 50
terawattheurs est-ce que c'est trop
optimiste ou pas
en réalité il est il faut bien
distinguer le court terme c'est à dire
passer l'hiver de la pérennité des
mesures sur le court terme oui ce sera
efficace parce que il nous manque un peu
de gaz parce que la Russie nous livre
plus on était dépendant à 17 % du gazon
c'est pas à 100% il nous manque RTO le
dit 10% d'électricité donc si tout le
monde les industriels les premiers et
les particuliers font 10% d'efforts on
passera ensuite le problème c'est
comment pérenniser ces mesures et là
effectivement il est important qu'il n'y
ait pas d'effet rebond et là il sera
important que tout le monde y compris
les entreprises elles en prend ma part
fassent le nécessaire et les jeunes nous
y poussent pour que ça dure même quand
la crise énergétique aiguë sera terminée
pour terminer Franck Tapiro il y a aussi
un aspect très politique
le parti de Marine Le Pen dit très
clairement que les sanctions sur
l'énergie contre la Russie sont
inefficaces avec un effet boomerang qui
nous condamne et qui nous pénalise
davantage si cet hiver tu fais très
froid si ça marche pas il y a un gros
risque politique que les Français lui
donnent raison il y a un risque
politique mais un risque majeur aussi
pour l'Europe et pour le monde entier
aujourd'hui avec ce conflit donc une
attitude comme ça vis-à-vis de là aussi
aujourd'hui serait prise vraiment à
l'envers de tout ce qu'il faut faire
stratégiquement vis-à-vis de l'Ukraine
et de la fin du conflit donc évidemment
c'est comme ça je vous dis tout à
l'heure c'est un casus Belly c'est une
cumule de mandat ou la somme de tous les
paradoxes oui tout se passe en même
temps aujourd'hui on apprend au moment
des mesures que la croissance sera très
mauvaise l'année prochaine donc il n'y a
que des choix à prendre qui sont pas les
meilleures choix mais les moins mauvais
des choix à prendre donc c'est ça la
politique aussi et la politique c'est
décidé et choisir c'est renoncer aussi
donc il faut savoir aussi
nous est imposé peut être ou pas merci
beaucoup merci d'être venu sur le
plateau de LCP pour ce débat on va à
présent accueillir notre grand témoin en
cette année de 60e anniversaire de la
fin de la guerre d'Algérie il a signé
avec George Marc Benhamou une série de
cinq documentaires exceptionnel dans
lesquels il raconte l'histoire de la
guerre d'Algérie mais aussi sa
préhistoire ils sont diffusés toute la
semaine sur l'antenne de LCP disponible
sur des plateformes de la chaîne pendant
15 jours Benjamin Stora nous rejoint
juste après l'invitation de Marco Polo
si on vous invite Benjamin Stora c'est
pour parler relation franco-algérienne
relation douloureuse conflictuelle
tumultueuse qui de mieux placé que vous
pour ausculter la mémoire celle de la
colonisation et de la guerre d'Algérie
pour parler aussi de l'intégration des
Français celle des descendants
d'Algériens vous l'enfant des deux pays
il est nécessaire encore et toujours de
regarder cette histoire en face parce
que visiblement les mémoires continuent
de saigner Benjamin Stora cette guerre
résonne en vous né à Constantine dans
une famille juive vous quittez l'Algérie
en 1962 trois mois après les accords
d'Évian aujourd'hui historiens vous êtes
la parole savante sur l'Algérie une
quarantaine d'ouvrages sur le sujet et
votre actualité c'est cette série
documentaire diffusées sur LCP cette
semaine à l'occasion des 60 ans de
l'indépendance 5 épisodes que vous avez
co-écris l'occasion de donner la parole
aux témoins d'hier et aux mémoires
d'aujourd'hui
cette terreur que j'ai vu en Algérie ses
horreurs c'est insupportable pourquoi
faire tout cela
la majorité de ma famille a été
assassinée c'est des choses très
violentes
mon souhait c'est que en plus elle est
vers une vraie réconciliation et que
c'est deux peuples puissent vraiment se
parler se reparler vraiment se reparler
pour réparer une blessure mémorielle
comme le dit Emmanuel Macron suivant vos
recommandations Benjamin Stora le
président a multiplié les gestes
mémorielles reconnaissances des crimes
de l'armée française à Alger demande de
pardon au harkis Bernier geste
d'apaisement en date la déclassification
des archives protégée par le secret
défense on va mettre en place une vraie
commission mixte d'historienne et
d'historiens on va ouvrir toutes nos
archives de part et d'autre
on va lui demander de travailler sur
toute la période début la colonisation
jusqu'à la fin de la guerre alors
Benjamin Stora Elisabeth borne est
attendu en Algérie des dimanche pour
deux jours preuve que les relations se
réchauffent entre Paris et Alger mais
faudra-t-il forcément passer par la
repentance pour dépasser cette page de
notre histoire à vous la parole
[Musique]
bonsoir Benjamin Stora et merci beaucoup
d'être là les passions douloureuses chez
Albin Michel et mémoire algérienne chez
bouquin sont toujours en librairie et
puis ces films qu'il faut absolument
voir ou revoir sur LCP avec des archives
inédites on va y revenir c'est bien plus
que l'histoire de la guerre d'Algérie
c'est aussi celle de sa genèse on va en
parler mais peut-être pour répondre tout
de suite à la question qui vous est
posée dans dans le sujet pourquoi c'est
toujours la même question 60 ans après
on est très loin de l'apaisement des
mémoires il y a eu des
reconnaissances des crimes commis par la
France mais il y a pas eu d'excuses
c'est le fameux mot qui est attendu par
les Algériens est-ce que ça pourrait
vraiment faire changer les choses ou pas
c'est 132 ans de présence française
c'est colossale c'est un siècle et demi
avec à la fin on le sait une sorte de
paysage dévasté l'exil l'exode des
pieds-noirs les massacres de harkis les
enlèvements européens mais aussi des
centaines de milliers d'Algériens qui
ont été tués pendant cette guerre des
millions de paysans algériens déplacés
on a 10 ans une sorte de paysage
désastreux il va falloir du temps du
temps et beaucoup de temps de pédagogie
aussi pour arriver à comprendre
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé dans toute
cette longue distance c'est très
difficile à dire parce que on a eu une
période dans quand même de déni en
France notamment et d'occultation et en
Algérie disons une période d'écriture de
survalorisation des réalisations de
cette histoire donc c'est seulement
maintenant qu'on commence à rentrer
véritablement dans la complexité de
cette histoire dans la tragédie
coloniale de cette histoire et donc il
faut du temps il faut de la patience
beaucoup de patience vous savez j'ai
commencé à travailler sur cette histoire
il y a 45 ans donc il faut je suis
patient quand même mais vous êtes
optimiste ah oui oui tout à fait parce
qu'entre le moment où j'ai commencé à
travailler dans les années 70 et
aujourd'hui il y a énormément de choses
qui ont bougé de reconnaissance de
reconnaissance d'ouverture d'archives de
parole prononcées et puis aussi les
acteurs alors on va en parler mais je
voudrais qu'on parle du film parce que
c'est un peu une œuvre totale que vous
proposez
5 x 52 minutes raconté par l'acteur
Benoît Magimel avec une musique
originale extraordinaire c'est aussi
mené par le producteur et réalisateur
Georges Marc Benhamou qu'est-ce que vous
vouliez faire avec ce film on a
l'impression que vous vouliez lever tous
les tabous faire au fond remonter à la
surface tous les noms dit de ces
mémoires oui c'est un peu l'objectif
c'est même beaucoup l'objectif de cette
de cette série de cinq épisodes qui fait
près de 5 heures d'abord il fallait
aller aux origines de la guerre
d'Algérie parce que dans le fond trop
souvent on a commencé à écrire cette
histoire par sa faim alors il y a une
espèce de tragédie inexplicable
engrenage absolument cruel on comprend
pas bien tous les aspects de cette
violence insensée mais si on remonte à
l'origine de la colonisation dans
s'aperçoit que la guerre de conquête a
été très très longue ce qu'on a expliqué
dans la première film la première 1830
scélération véritablement jusqu'en 1880
on a 50 ans de conquêtes c'est colossal
et donc à partir de là on peut
comprendre la violence je voudrais
d'ailleurs qu'on remonte alors un peu
moins loin que le XIXe siècle mais 1936
avant la guerre donc et cette archive
absolument incroyable nous sommes dans
le grand stade municipal à Alger août
1936 à l'occasion du 1er Congrès
musulman et messalihadj pionniers père
du nationalisme algérien va joindre le
geste à la parole avec cette phrase qui
va tout changer regardez en août 1936 il
lance le premier Congrès musulman dans
le Grand Stade d'Alger
personnes à court pour soutenir le Front
populaire et sa promesse d'égalité dans
la République
jusqu'à ce qu'un homme arrive pour
troubler la fête
il y a un silence
surprenant
un très grand
et là il a une idée géniale
CBC
il a attrapé une poignée de cette terre
il a levé
devant le public et il a dit en arabe
cette terre n'est pas à vendre
racontez-nous comment vous avez réussi à
reconstituer à la fois des archives que
personne n'avait vu puis la fille de
Messali Hadj qui raconte alors les
archives d'abord le stade effectivement
les avaient pas été montré leur on voit
pas mais ça dit dans les notables en
fait qui avait été invité par le
gouvernement général pour le geste en
lui-même et bien sûr Giannina la fille
de Messali qui est joué un grand rôle
dans ma vie personnelle parce que grâce
à elle j'ai pu écrire une grande partie
de la biographie de son père il y a 40
ans 50 ans et qui a pu reconstituer ce
geste parce que son père l'avait écrit
dans ses mémoires et ça avait été aussi
vérifié par un certain nombre de grands
témoins de cette époque là qui était
vivant cette scène ce geste incroyable
va effectivement se transmettre de
génération en génération ce qu'on
découvre dans le film aussi c'est toutes
les occasions manquées de stopper les
bains de sang vous avez un personnage
peut-être la jeune génération ne le sait
pas trop Germaine Tillion la grande
résistante l'ethnologue elle va essayer
de s'interposer de faire comprendre
qu'il ne faut pas se voilà se tuer sans
te tuer bon ça n'a pas marché mais
pourquoi vouloir la mettre en avant elle
est pas la seule bien sûr mais c'est une
figure exemplaire parce qu'elle a essayé
elle a écrit un livre qui s'appelle les
ennemis complémentaires ou à l'explique
la guerre entre entre frère entre
voisins entre gens qui se connaissent et
la plus terrible des guerres c'est aussi
des guerres civiles en Algérie c'est
aussi ça c'est aussi cette question là
elle a essayé de mettre fin à
l'effusions de sang mais aussi Albert
Camus lorsqu'il a écrit
civile en janvier 1956 il a été pris à
partie des deux côtés par les ultras
partisans de l'Algérie française mais
aussi par certains dirigeants du FLN qui
ne voulaient pas disons de cette sorte
de trait permettant d'épargner la vie
des civils et Albert Camus ensuite a été
emporté disons par cette guerre cet
engrenage cette terreur qui a existé
notamment à partir de la bataille
d'Alger en 1957 et le bain de sang et là
des deux côtés avec cette trace un des
débiles de la torture de l'armée
française regardez
les fait torturer
puisque je suis obligé d'utiliser ce mot
là parce qu'il y en a pas d'autres j'ai
fait torturer environ 1500 arabe
mais je donnais comme conditions à mes
officiers à mes officiers de
renseignement
de que la l'intégrité physique et morale
de l'individu ne soit absolument pas
touchés
48 heures
[Musique]
sur la bouche et puis avec un grand
exercice
que ces techniques de torture des échos
bien après dans notre histoire récente
oui enfin les Français ont commencé
l'utilisation c'est de ce type de
pratique notamment en Indochine ça a été
repris ensuite par les américains
notamment à Guantanamo question grave de
ce quand on entend ça on se dit que les
blessures comment voilà ne guériront pas
demain Elisabeth borne est en visite off
matériel en Algérie ce week-end après la
visite d'Emmanuel Macron c'était c'était
très récent fin août alors comme à
chaque fois je sais que vous êtes
consulté vous ne serez pas de la
délégation cette fois-ci vous aviez
accompagné le président français
qu'est-ce qu'elle doit dire qu'est-ce
qu'elle doit faire
je pense que ce qu'elle doit dire
d'abord c'est de mettre en application
la déclaration qui a été adoptée par les
deux présidents à Alger il y a un
certain nombre de choses qui ont été
décidées au niveau notamment de la
coopération économique mais aussi sur la
question mémorielle c'est-à-dire
d'essayer de mettre en oeuvre en place
cette commission d'historien dont on
parlait les deux présidents de la
République c'est dire de faire en sorte
qu'on passe à l'écriture de l'histoire
et que l'histoire soit pas simplement
jouer entre les mains idéologues qui
instrumentalisent en permanence ces
conflits de mémoire pour se légitimer
donc passer à l'écriture de l'histoire
c'est très difficile elle existe des
deux côtés aujourd'hui encore parce que
on se souvient des mots d'Emmanuel
Macron qui a parlé de rente mémorielle
mais la France aussi oui parce que si
vous regardez par exemple tout un
vocabulaire un langage ou une façon
d'être d'une grande partie de l'extrême
droite française la guerre d'Algérie est
très présente le rapport à l'islam à
l'immigration à l'autre la question
coloniale il y a quand même encore
disons des sortes de rebond mémorielles
autour de la guerre d'Algérie qui sont
instrumentalisés
le doyen d'âge ici à l'Assemblée
nationale député rassemblement national
qui avait des mots sur sur la guerre
d'Algérie
française tout à fait il avait
fait un discours qui ranimer la flamme
des souvenirs de l'Algérie française
bien sûr ce qui prouve que tout ça n'est
pas en train entièrement aboli disparu
etc une dernière question d'actualité il
y a un débat en France sur le général
Bugeaud d'ailleurs vous en parlait
pouvoir militaire et colonial le plus
dur c'était le gouverneur général
d'Algérie partisans d'une invasion
massive il a il a eu comme idée
d'exégations vous parlez des enfumades
qui ont asphyxié des Algériens est-ce
qu'il faut des baptiser les rues les
places bugeaux c'est le combat de
certains
de généraux de l'armée d'Afrique l'armée
de conquête qui sont sur les frontons
des rues des boulevards il y en a
beaucoup j'ai pas tous les citer la
mauricière Saint-Arnaud Bujo bien sûr
etc moi je crois qu'il faut expliquer
d'abord dans un premier temps un énorme
travail pédagogie à faire à l'intérieur
de la société française parce que si on
décide par en haut d'enlever des plaques
de débatisés etc sans que les gens ne
connaissent cette histoire savent pas ce
qui s'est passé il y aura une
incompréhension il y aura une formidable
incompréhension il faut vous savez on
peut pas faire l'économie de tout un
travail de pédagogie d'explication ce
film contribue à sa place modestement
qui est diffusé sur la chaîne
faut voir c'est 5 documentaires en ligne
sur les plateformes de la Chaîne
Parlementaire merci beaucoup merci
Benjamin Stora vous restez avec moi
parce qu'on va accueillir à présent nos
affranchis pour leur partie prix ce soir
Clément Perrot nous raconte ce colloque
du rassemblement national qui s'est tenu
en catimini à l'Assemblée aujourd'hui à
l'occasion des 50 ans du parti le pénis
et puis un nouveau visage dans cette
émission ffteel de libération pour
chroniquer l'actualité des villes et des
territoires et puis une nouvelle
histoire d'école avec l'enseignant et
Yanis roder nos affranchis les voici
bonsoir à tous les trois on vais
commencer par vous ce soir Clément vous
avez suivi ce colloque de rassemblement
national sont embour ni trompette on l'a
compris Marine Le Pen joue sobre la
sobriété c'est d'actualité pour marquer
les 50 ans du parti oui c'est bien de se
terminer Myriam et c'était à l'Assemblée
il y a quelques minutes ce colloque très
modestement appelé de l'espoir au
pouvoir donc colloque du rassemblement
national en fait c'était pour célébrer
les 50 ans du RN ancien FN alors c'est
vrai que c'était un anniversaire plutôt
discret pas de champagne on a fait ça
dans la salle Victor Hugo c'est une
salle qui est assez grande mais qui se
trouve quand même au troisième sous-sol
d'un bâtiment annexe du Palais Bourbon
donc il y avait quand même une volonté
d'être discret les députés à Rennes
expliquait que c'était un coloc très
studio en réalité c'était presque
effectivement en catimini alors pourquoi
cette discrétion ils font profil bas et
non pas envie de le célébrer cet
anniversaire et bien parce que
l'anniversaire et bien c'est se
replonger dans le passé et au ARN on n'a
pas forcément envie de revivre les
années FN des années Jean-Marie
Jean-Marie Le Pen et cette figure qui a
longtemps écrasé le parti on se souvient
de ses excès en se souvient aussi bien
sûr de ces dérapages et cette hyper
révélateur Jean-Marie Le Pen ce soir n'a
pas été invité à ce colloque preuve que
sa figure dérange je vais vous proposer
d'écouter une députée du RN à ce sujet
c'était Edwig Diaz une député qui est
plutôt de la génération Marine Le Pen
faut dire aussi ce qui est Monsieur
Monsieur Le Pen est un homme d'un
certain âge aujourd'hui moi si tu avais
été Jean-Marie Le Pen président toujours
aujourd'hui président du Front national
je pense que je ne serai pas au
rassemblement national
tranquillement alors vous voyez c'est un
peu caché ce Jean-Marie que je ne
saurais voir pour pas mal de députés je
vous propose maintenant d'écouter Marine
Le Pen s'est exprimée au tout début de
ce colloque elle cherche plus à arrondir
les angles
il n'est pas question pour nous de faire
une croix sur l'apport le courage la
pulmonicacité la persévérance qui a été
celle de Jean-Marie Le Pen alors
quelques nouvelles de Jean-Marie Le Pen
d'après mes informations ce soir il ne
déprime pas il organise même sa contre
soi et au château de montré tout à
Saint-Cloud avec on va dire c'est vrai
ami le RN FN plutôt historique était
quand même présent ce soir puisqu'il y
avait Bruno golniche parmi les
intervenants
se pose en partie quoi normale des
diabolisées institutionnalisés forts de
ses 89 députés
le gouvernement maintenant puisqu'ils
sont passés de 8 à 89 députés c'est une
entrée en force au Parlement dans
l'hémicycle ce résultat c'est sans doute
un tournant historique pour le
rassemblement national qui n'est plus en
position simplement de commentateur
critique mais qui devient vraiment un
acteur de la vie politique française
c'est désormais le premier groupe de
position à l'Assemblée nationale et ça
ça donne des ailes à certains députés je
vous propose écoutez Laurent jacobelli
député de Moselle en étant au coeur du
réacteur j'allais dire nous apprenons
beaucoup sur l'état législatif de notre
pays ce qui fournira encore plus
d'arguments pour arriver au pouvoir en
2027 2027 c'est ça la dernière marche
après Macron ce sera nous après Macron
ce sera nous 2027 je peux vous dire que
c'est une obsession pour de nombreux
députés du rassemblement national n'ont
pas de tabou là-dessus pour eux c'est
presque arithmétique c'est presque le
sens de l'histoire ils arriveront aux
affaires Marine Le Pen sera élu
présidente de la République et ils
auront la majorité dans l'hémicycle
attention quand même avec cette
confiance ils ont aujourd'hui 89
nouveaux députés ici jusqu'ici on ne
peut pas dire que ce soit tous des
ténors de l'hémicycle et certains
brillent surtout par leur discrétion
pour le moment merci beaucoup Clément
Benjamin storama comment vous regardez
ça le rassemblement national qui s'écrit
il y a 50 ans avec des anciens de l'os
des néo fascistes des
collaborationnistes qui sont à 89
députés aujourd'hui est-ce qu'ils ont
changé est-ce que ce parti changer selon
vous la vieille question qu'on pose
toujours évidemment classique à la fois
la même chose Vichy l'Algérie bien sûr
et en même temps différent parce qu'il y
a une nouvelle génération une façon de
vouloir accéder au pouvoir et
d'apparaître comme un parti de
gouvernement moi ce qui me pose question
aujourd'hui toujours ils sont très forts
c'est vrai 89 députés mais non pas
d'allier ils sont toujours pas d'allier
politique il y a pas d'autres ralliement
autour de je ne sais pas comment ils
vont arriver c'est compliqué telle
assurance sans aucun allié politique il
faut quand même qu'ils aient qui
réfléchissent à ça or pour l'instant
pour l'instant il y a pas beaucoup de
partis politiques traditionnelles qui
sont prêts à l'alliance officielle
publique avec le Front national ça
n'existe même qu'ils ne sont plus un
parti anti-système vous diriez
qu'aujourd'hui les anti-systèmes les
contestataires c'est plus les insoumis à
l'assemblée que le RN non non je crois
que c'est l'anti-système c'est un petit
peu maintenant une technique généralisée
au plan mondial c'est à dire que on ne
peut accéder au pouvoir que si on est
anti-système et quand on est même au
pouvoir on est anti-système regardez
bolsonaro il est lui-même devenu un
anti-système tout en étant le chef du
système extraordinaire on est rentré
dans un monde fantastique on va suivre
d'ailleurs des élections au Brésil c'est
dans trois scènes le deuxième tour
bonsoir ffteel bonsoir ravi de vous
accueillir dans cette émission alors des
histoires de ville des histoires de
campagne et ce soir vous voulez nous
raconter comment les réseaux sociaux ont
eu raison d'un projet urbanistique
important le réaménagement du parvis de
la Tour Eiffel effectivement c'est aussi
un des éléments de notre patrimoine
national la Tour Eiffel donc plus de 6
millions de visiteurs par an 20 millions
aux abords du monument et pourtant quel
spectacle désolant quand on y va un
fatra de baraque de l'eau cotechnique de
kiosque portique de sécurité tout ça
entouré par une très haute barrière de
verre bref c'est pas très beau quoi non
surtout pour un site classé à l'Unesco
alors voilà pourquoi il y a 4 ans la
mairie de Paris a lancé un concours
d'architectes qui a été remplacé
remportée par le l'architecte français
Thomas Corbasson avec ce projet de
pavillon semi enterré végétalisé on voit
à l'écran et alors on a comparé ce
projet à quoi
de critiques maison de Hobbit on a pu
lire sur les réseaux sociaux alors
est-ce que c'est une critique ou est-ce
que c'était un compliment parce que
c'est en même temps un projet un peu
trop Glaude comme ça discret et sobre
puisque le mot est et d'actualité et qui
en tout cas conforme aux souhait de
Gustave Eiffel qui voulait vraiment que
la tour émerge comme ça Desjardins alors
pour reprendre la chronologie quand
Thomas corbason a été désigné en mai
2019 à l'époque personne n'a rien dit
mais au printemps 2021 donc deux ans
plus tard voilà que émerge sur Twitter
un hashtag donc vite devenu viral ça
cache Paris voilà et dernière cette
bannière c'est des milliers
d'internautes qui dénoncent le décalage
souvent à juste titre d'ailleurs entre
les beaux projets de la mairie
et la réalité d'une ville sale bruyante
et souvent inhospitalière et voilà la
proposition de l'agence Chartier
Corbasson tout à fait écologique pris
dans la tourment des réseaux sociaux
ensuite il y a l'agent l'association
France naturo environnement qui prend le
relais qui lance une pétition pour
demander le retrait du projet qui accusé
de bétonner le site de massacrer des
arbres et tout ça pour implanter des
commerces et des bagages
qui s'est enchaîné voilà un platane
centenaire pour empêcher disait-il son
abattage donc tout ça était fou ou pas
le débat c'est cristallisé autour de cet
arbre remarquable et l'architecte lui
dit mais il n'a jamais été question
d'abattre cet arbre et même il courait
aucun danger puisque la première
fondation de des pavillons était situé à
plus de 8 mètres de cet arbre mais bon
pour faire taire la polémique la mairie
de Paris a décidé quand même d'enterrer
le projet oui alors quelle est la morale
de cette histoire cheftel moi ça
m'inspire trois réflexions d'abord c'est
vraiment un décalage si vous voulez de
temporalité entre le temps des projets
urbains qui un temps très long qui peut
prendre 10-15 ans 20 ans même et celui
des réseaux sociaux c'est le temps long
contre l'immédiat et ce télescopage ne
fonctionne pas toujours après il y a le
rôle des fake news qui se viralise à la
vitesse de l'éclair et que rien ne peut
contrecarrer comme me l'a dit
l'architecte moi je ferai jamais 100 000
vues sur Twitter et enfin ça soulève un
problème démocratique parce que ce qu'il
faut pas oublier c'est que ce projet il
a été validé par un vote du Conseil de
Paris donc l'assemblée municipale des
représentants du peuple de Paris donc la
question le qu'on peut se poser c'est
que la mairie de Paris par l'acheter ou
lassitude en fait a donné raison à la
vox populi plutôt qu'aux citoyens qui
l'ont élus à la foule fut-elle virtuelle
plutôt qu'au peuple politique qui lui
est bien réel les ravages de la
twistérisation de la vie politique merci
beaucoup elles vont enchaîne avec vous
professeur Robert une nouvelle histoire
d'école vous aviez envie ce soir Yanis
de revenir sur un documentaire qui a
diffusé nos amis de Public Sénat le
collège d'à côté réalisé par Marc
adergall film qui a suscité de très très
nombreux commentaires sur les réseaux
sociaux et qui pointait le racisme
anti-blanc décomplexé en parlant même
ces commentaires d'une bande-annonce
pour le grand remplacement oui tout à
fait Myriam j'ai été alerté par ses
propos un peu surprenants je voulais
juger par moi-même et le film commence
ainsi au début de l'année au début de
l'année prochaine il y aura beaucoup de
problèmes comme des petites guerres
entre nous et pas la même catégorie quoi
évidemment on s'inquiète alors qu'est-ce
qui pourrait mal se passer en fait la
mixité Myriam parce que l'académie de
Paris a lancé il y a 5 ans l'expérience
dite au collège les élèves issus d'un
quartier bobo et un autre bien plus
populaire fréquente le même
établissement scolaire histoire de
mettre fin à la ghettoïsation mais dans
les faits la mixité ce n'est pas si
simple on voit dans le documentaire les
appréhensions les méfiances les préjugés
ceux de Fanta et de ses camarades mais
aussi ceux de d'autres jeunes filles qui
véhiculent la crainte de leurs parents
elles disent par exemple les profs sont
moins sévères et les contrôles moins
compliqués
en voilà la peur du manque de
stimulation et donc aussi évidemment du
climat scolaire dégradé comme le dit
notre élève elle dit nos parents nous
ont mis dans la tête que c'était une
école de racaille mais on voit aussi des
images parlantes sur l'une des
réalisateur nous montre un groupe
d'élèves que des blanches et l'image
suivante à un autre groupe que des noirs
toutes ces difficultés nous montrent
aussi que la mixité c'est un combat et
c'est essentiel nous savons Myriam que
ce sont les élèves les plus pauvres dont
le niveau s'effondre situation qui est
aggravée par l'évitement scolaire et la
fuite vers l'enseignement privé mais
vous savez en réalité Myriam je peux
rassurer ces petites jeunes filles mais
n'importe où les bons élèves restent de
bons élèves et la confrontation à
l'altérité est aussi en réalité un
apprentissage de fait mixité sociale
rime souvent aujourd'hui avec mixité
culturelle car nombre de quartiers de
nos grandes métropoles sont peuplées
d'enfants issus de l'immigration si la
France veut faire nation les jeunes nos
jeunes doivent se confronter
pacifiquement au sein de l'école à
d'autres dont les cultures et les
visions du monde sont autant ou seront
autant d'ouverture pour les uns comme
pour les autres et les préjugés
exactement car il ne s'agit là en rien
de racisme des complexé alors est-ce
qu'on a des raisons d'espérer est-ce
qu'on peut croire à la mise en place
dans ce type d'école dans ces quartiers
là d'une réelle la société sociale
géographique oui je le pense et c'est
d'ailleurs la vie du réalisateur et
c'est ce qu'ils veulent montrer dans son
film on y voit les élèves se
rapprochaient peu à peu guider par des
professionnels admirables prof CPE chef
d'établissement remarquable d'ailleurs
d'engagement et qui font de l'école ce
qu'elle est un formidable outil
d'émancipation et liberté mais vous
savez il suffit pas de décider la mixité
sociale pour qu'elle fonctionne il faut
l'accompagner et notamment par la
pédagogie de projet ici c'est une pièce
de théâtre c'est à cette condition et
uniquement à cette condition que l'école
construira du commun il répondra à ses
promesses aux promesses républicaines en
cassant les stéréotypes et les préjugés
créer du commun je retiens ça ce soir
merci beaucoup Yanis roder une réaction
à cette à cette chronique et à ce
documentaire vous aviez entendu parler
de cette polémique
benjaminière dans le département d'arabe
donc et puis à Paris 8 et apparaît 13 en
première année donc je sais à peu près
je connais il y a pas il y a pas
longtemps je crois qu'il y a aussi le
problème du contenu d'emmanuels
scolaires en histoire il faut former les
maîtres aussi pour répondre aux
questions posées par ces nouvelles
populations scolaires sur des nouvelles
histoires en termes républicains je
parle il y a tout un travail de
pédagogie à faire parce que sinon ils
ont le sentiment de pas être compris
dans leur identité leur histoire il faut
ramener ça sur une histoire républicaine
à partir de leur propre histoire
des choses à vous dire professeur
d'histoire historiens merci beaucoup
merci Benjamin Sora d'être venu sur le
plateau de LCP merci à vous les
affranchis à très bientôt avant de se
quitter cette photo le visage Dani
Ernaux je te sais que ça va faire
plaisir femme française couronnée du
prix Nobel de littérature l'écrivaine de
82 ans la première à avoir exploré la
question sociale en littérature et la
question intime du corps des femmes
deuxième prix Nobel français décidément
qui a dit que notre pays était en déclin
à demain
[Musique]